tell us joy he he he does not seem to
understand
the difference between um a racist
country
and a lot of them don't seem to
understand so what did he say that was
so bad well
in his response to the state of the
union address that interminable
soporific
ridiculous state of the union address in
which joe biden barely
awake himself put the rest of the nation
to sleep bludgeoning us
into submission with lists of trillion
dollar spending items
and also suggested this old white man
that america is systemically racist
then tim scott got up and he said well
no america is not racist
and just because i've experienced racism
in my personal life does not mean
that america is completely racist which
is what mature adults think about the
world
just because a bad thing happened to you
does not mean the entire world is
against you
just because people have been very
anti-semitic to me does not mean that
all of america or its systems are
anti-semitic
so tim scott says this about being black
in america and this of course set off
the left
into a frenzy of apoplectic idiocy
a hundred years ago kids in classrooms
were taught the color of their skin was
their most
important characteristic and if they
looked a certain way
they were inferior today cues are being
taught
that the color of their skin defines
them again
and if they look a certain way they're
an oppressor
from colleges to corporations to our
culture people are making money
and gaining power by pretending we
haven't made any progress
at all by doubling down on the divisions
we've worked so hard to heal you know
this stuff is wrong
hear me clearly america
is not a racist country
it's backwards to fight discrimination
with
different types of discrimination and
it's wrong
to try to use our painful past to
dishonestly shut down debates in the
present
okay of course every single word that
tim scott says there is exactly correct
and this is what sets off the left this
is what makes them so mad so he was
subtweeting a couple of folks there
one of the people that he was
substituting for sure was ibrahim
kennedy so when he says it is wrong to
fight discrimination with discrimination
that is a precise counter to ibrah max
kennedy who has said discrimination of
the past
requires discrimination today so max
kennedy not only disagrees with tim
scott
he was basically being subtweeted by tim
scott right there tim scott was saying
every max candy's perverse view of
america
and the and the ramifications of ibramex
kennedy's views are bad for america
tim scott saying that set off ibra max
kennedy so every max kennedy is an
absolute grifter i mean there's a guy
who's raised tens of millions of dollars
based on the lie that not only is
america racist but that it is better for
america
if we treat every american by their
racially essential characteristics which
is racism
okay so tim scott tweeted out that
particular line from the speech
hear me clearly america is not a racist
country and ibram excandi then tweeted
back
the heartbeat of racism is denial we can
hear the heartbeat clearly
okay so april max kennedy loves to
engage i mean he's such a grifter he
loves to engage
in these kafka traps so a kafka trap is
where you accuse somebody of a crime it
comes from
franz kafka's the trial you accuse
somebody of a crime and then the person
denies the crime
you say well if you really were innocent
you wouldn't be denying it would you
and so the kafka trap here is if you say
that america is not racist
this makes you a racist because you're
denying that america is racist
because only a truly non-racist person
would acknowledge that america is in
fact racist
you see how this works okay now it makes
no sense
full on catch-22 because there is no way
to get out of that trap
it creates a completely unfalsifiable
situation it is literally the scene
from monty python and the holy grail in
which they decide that to determine
whether a witch is a witch or not
if you throw her in the water and she
and she floats
this means she's a witch and must be
burned and if you throw her in the water
and she sings this means that she was
not a witch
and she's innocent but sadly she's dead
that is how anti-racism works in every
max kennedy's world
and by the way he's a racist ever
mexican is consistently saying things
about how white people are inherently
plagued with white supremacy
ever mexican is consistently judging
people on the basis of the color of
their skin alone
and suggesting that america's racial
institutions are inherently racist
because
there's unequal outcome by race now as
i've said many times
you could you could take any room in
america any room full of people in
america and draw a line
along any angle in that room that
separates the population in half and you
will find
inequalities in that room you'll find
that on average one group is taller and
one group is shorter or one group is
fatter or one group is skinnier or one
group has a higher iq and one group has
a lower iq or one group has more
criminals and the other has fewer
criminals
there is no line you could draw in any
room in america in which the outcome on
both sides of that line is exactly
the same on all aspects that can be
marked right that is just not the way
that
statistics work that's not the way the
world works and that's particularly true
when culture makes a difference which we
know that it does if you took a bunch of
white people from appalachia who are
living in poverty and you put them next
to a bunch of white
upper class people living in manhattan
they're going to have
very different life outcomes and that
doesn't have anything to do with color
that doesn't mean that the system
is discriminating on the basis of
whiteness this is the point that charles
murray makes in his book coming apart he
talks about cultural differences between
white people because he said listen i
keep getting ripped on
for suggesting that culture makes a
difference in the outcome of your life
because people say that has to do with
race so i'm just gonna write a book
about white people
i'm just gonna write about a book about
how there are differences within
white america in how your lifestyle
makes a difference
to your outcome it doesn't matter they
still call charles murray or racist
because
this is one of their favorite things to
do but you don't have to be related
this is just a religious world view and
tim scott has attacked a religious world
view
and the left sees him as a heretic and
heretics must be burned
so it's not just abram x kennedy who is
the high priest of woken
it's throughout the media it's
throughout the culture to have joy behar
lecturing tim scott about systemic
racism now
there's a word that people on left like
to use about stuff like this
white-splaining
joy behar explaining to tim scott about
systemic racism
is just absurd at the highest level
first of all joy behar cannot understand
basic concepts she really
has a deficiency in in intellectually
understanding things
but here she is attempting to lecture
tim scott
a black man in america who acknowledges
that he's experienced significant racism
in his life
about what systemic racism actually is
tell us joy who by the way dressed in
blackface
in costume as erica and still has her
job here she is
now tim scott he he does not seem to
understand
and a lot of them don't seem to
understand the difference between
um a racist country and
a systemic ra and systemic racism they
don't seem to get the difference yes
maybe it's not a racist country maybe
americans
the majority are not racist but we live
in a country with systemic racism
oh well it's not a racist country but
you know it's still systemic racism
because even though america is not
racist it's systems are racist but you
can't explain how the systems are racist
because
legal racism has been illegal in the
united states since the 1960s
so as i've said before the term systemic
racism can mean a bunch of things it can
mean you're a racist they don't say that
they it can mean
that every american deep down has
implicit
bias they sometimes mean that they could
say that it means legalized racism which
is not true because that's been
federally illegal
since the 1960s or they can mean that
history has consequences and because
it used to be that there was a lot of
racism in the united states that that
has
far-reaching consequences downstream
which is true of all history
right it is always true that history has
impact in the here and now
but the question is how you heal that
and when you say systemic racism the
idea is there must be a quote unquote
systemic solution
well that but that's not right the
reality is the single best way to escape
poverty is the same for every single
american
get married don't have kids until you're
married get a job that's it
if you do those things it doesn't matter
what race you are you will
succeed in america you will not live in
permanent poverty in america
statistically speaking according to the
brookings institute
but they don't want to talk about that
right because that puts personal onus on
you and so much of the left's belief
in in what needs to happen is that you
don't have any personal responsibility
the government has to take
responsibility for everything
i know what you're thinking it's time to
bin some more ben shapiro videos well
you are right
you should but first like and subscribe
perfect i'll see you in the next video